Thank You Ladia thank you your
Excellencies distinguished colleagues
ladies and gentlemen first of all I
would like to warmly welcome all of you
in Poland hosting this conference is a
great honor and recognition for our
country potential I would like to thank
the ftth cancel Europe for organizing
this important event in polite there are
several myths about FTTH but two of them
are the most common first there is no
demand for it and it is risky business
we don't need such high bandwidth second
we can't afford as dth is too expensive
from end users and who will pay for this
kind of service back in the 1920s David
Sarnoff when asked about invest in the
radial answered the wireless music box
has no imaginable commercial value and
who will pay for a message sent to
nobody in particular 40 years on decker
according reject the Beatles saying we
don't like the sound and the guitar
music is on the way out when I want what
I want to say with these anecdotes is
that we need to be visionaries not to
miss the opportunity what we see as
unnecessary now can completely change
the future in the next two days we will
be discussing how to create a connected
continent and the smart word never
before was discover action more
important and up-to-date our economy
increasingly depend on connectivity
connectivity that will ensure
competitiveness a sustainable growth
but we down to the modern infrastructure
we are going nowhere and today many
people cannot imagine life without the
internet even if not everyone can enjoy
a fast connection if we reflect back to
the beginning of the commercial use of
the internet and we see compare it with
today's situation one thing is obvious
consumers and businesses went mobile
globba globba and virtual demanding
higher and higher bandwidth a recent
survey of boston consulting group has
shown that fifty-eight percent of people
would rather give up wine for a week
then lose the internet connection sixty
percent would prefer to give up coffee
and films for a week rather than they
smartphones a further nine percent would
rather go unwashed for a week then lose
the internet connectivity it brings us
back to the most common myths about FTTH
there is no demand for such high
bandwidth but is it really the case
let's begin with users what do modern
consumers want they want fast download
of high-resolution photos and videos
they need to handle big data many of
death of them have already chosen the
stable and reliable ftth technology but
the expectations of future consumers
will be even more advanced stability and
speed of internet connection is also
very important for companies that
operate across the borders public health
institution financial institution
schools media and creative sectors
including gaming industry I can create I
can easily imagine that thanks to the
universal access to ultra fast
internet people could easily video call
their families wherever they mission
takes them students from the less
developed countries and xual areas could
study it from home at the best
university thanks to a learning
platforms stay-at-home mothers could
work from home and not miss out of the
child's first step elderly people could
consult a doctor without leaving home
awaiting in lights broadband and icts
can ensure all human beings young or old
women and men boys and girls the
opportunity to fulfill their dreams and
ambition but this is only the beginning
I'm sure that when people get access to
the fibre broadband they will find many
ways to use it the demand for ultra-fast
connections has become our mutual
concern the time has come to take action
and address these needs now a lot has
changed in Poland over the past few
years with regard to broadband access
when it comes to ftth we cannot compare
our phasers the asia-pacific region or
scandinavia but we are on the right
track very briefly we adopted National
Broadband Plan it goal is to implement
project aimed at building the
infrastructure to ensure high speed
internet access currently with you fans
you are constructing the backbone and
distribution network regional networks
the project assumes creation of around
fifty thousand kilometers of fiber
networks which would be open for all
telecom operators willing to provide NGA
services by the end of 2014 almost
17,000 kilometers of fiber networks were
built implementation of regional
broadband network
will reduce investment costs especially
for smaller entrepreneurs operating
unless urbanized and less profitable
areas we have already observed some
positive outcomes our last event or a
shot that fiber networks have reached
towns with population of less than 500
we built faster and we built more with
minimum increase in public spending also
fiber is crucial for development of
mobile networks without stable optical
fiber connection we won't be able to
take full advantage of the highest
mobile standards LTE lte-advanced 5g it
is that simple at the moment there are
already several million FTTH
subscription in Europe Sweden which
hosted at the g8 conference last year a
shining example but Europe has still
plenty of work to do if we want to
compete on the global digital market in
2014 forty-six percent of European home
still didn't has covered by fast
next-generation broadband in rural areas
it was even worse only one of our out of
eight homes has broadband connection
what can and needs to be done we need to
start rolling out new networks cheaper
and faster separately nor governments
nor neither government nor entrepreneurs
can afford this investment public funds
should be invested in those area in
which entrepreneurs would provide their
services in the last place healthy
development of market requires stable
regulatory environment and adopting
French fresh
approaches this means moving away from X
anti-regulation to ex post actions in my
view currently there is no room for
strict regulation in the market and for
imposing a full set of regulatory
remedies the NRI must combine its
objectives to protect competition with
that if with its task to stimulate
invest so much needed to create the
digital single world in the present
world the regulator and operators must
cooperate it won't get as far is both
sides big day heels in we live in one
ecosystem both the regulators and
operators must understand the situation
the recipe is cooperation both sides
need to clearly communicate communicate
the policies in order to create
conditions for broadband rollout
moreover bleeding engines isn't
everything we need to stimulate the
demand therefore one of the objectives
of operators and public authorities
should be dissemination of knowledge
among potential consumers about new
technologies and their benefits we need
to take these steps because our economy
increasingly depends on connectivity we
don't know what the future holds but we
know that the world has been changing
communication will require
ever-increasing bit rates digital
economy will be an economy of
interconnected sectors therefore we need
to encourage more cooperation the future
is now that is why I wish all of us
successful discussion and determination
in creating
the connected continent thank you so
much